[MUSIC]
For as long as I can remember,
I have loved election day.
When I was a kid, I used to follow
my parents into the voting booth,
pushing each little red
button with intense focus.
After we got home, my parents and
I would sit in the kitchen and
talk about how their small decisions,
and those little buttons,
linked to big decisions, happening
at the highest levels of government.
On my tenth birthday, my grandfather
gave me a blank index card and
told me to write the top five things
that I wanted to be when I grew up.
Next to teacher and ballerina, I wrote
that I wanted to work at the White House.
Now, maybe this is because I grew up
in a family that watched the West Wing
every week.
But I like to think that it's because of
all of those times that I'd followed my
parents into the voting booth.
My grandfather took that index card,
dated it, and
sealed it in an envelope,
which I promptly forgot about.
But I found that envelope stuffed in
the back of a bookshelf 14 years later,
one month after being offered
a job at the White House.
Now, anyone who knows me could
tell you that my childhood
love of government has only grown.
And to this day, I do still love to vote.
But most people don't share my enthusiam.
In fact, voter turnout in US midterm
elections tends to hover just below 40%.
If someone can win with a plurality of
the votes, that means that they can
get elected to lead with the support
of less than 20% of their constituents.
Now, you may be asking,
why does this matter for me?
I want you to take a moment and
think of the products and
services that you use every day.
Who provides them?
Raise your hand if you're thinking
of a big tech company right now.
Okay, most of us.
Now raise your hand if you're
thinking of government.
One or two, but we've got some work to do.
I've had a lot of conversations
with my peers here at
business school about
the role of government.
And many people have expressed that
they don't see any connection between
the actions they take and
the outcomes that government provides.
But in reality, the work of government
touches each of our lives in
countless ways that go beyond
the headlines, every single day.
Let's take a look at your day today.
Your alarm goes off,
you look at the clock and get out of bed.
You check your favorite weather app out
and maybe take a morning medication.
Let's say that you scroll through
notifications on iPhone while eating your
breakfast and decide to Google a
particularly interesting news story before
moving on with your day.
Let's recap what just happened.
Who set the time on your alarm clock?
The National Institute of Standards and
Technology, a US government agency.
Your weather app is pulling data
from the National Weather Service.
And that medication, why did you
assume that it's safe and effective?
Because consciously you're not,
you have faith in the work of the Food and
Drug Administration.
As for the iPhone,
do you know who provided the early
stage financing for Apple?
The US Government Small Business
Investment Company Program.
Venture capitalists only
started to take note after
government funding got Apple
to a proof of concept.
And as for that Google search
of the morning headline,
It was possible in no small part because
of the National Science Foundation,
which funded the early work
on Google's algorithm.
A lot of people here in Silicon Valley see
government as red tape and regulations.
But that overlooks the massive role that
government has played in spurring some of
our most disruptive innovations.
In many ways, the work of
government is the invisible thread
holding the fabric of society together.
We haven't even left your house yet
in the example that I just walked through.
And there are millions of lives even
more intimately touched by government
every day through things like
unemployment insurance, health care, and
public education.
But while its work touches each of our
life every day, whether we know it or not,
too many of us remain uninterested
in the public sector.
Now I recognize that
government is not perfect.
There are many improvements to be
made in terms of efficiencies and
user experience,
let alone tangible policy outcomes.
But in the same way that public
companies need shareholders to
provide accountability and counsel,
government needs shareholders too.
And that comes in the form
of active civic engagement.
There are countless ways to get involved,
but
the one that tends to come
up the most is voting.
Now, for any of you who may still be
on the fence about the value of voting,
I could give you an impassioned
plea about how it's your duty,
given those who fought for
your right to enter the voting booth.
I could tell you about the importance
of having a representative sample
of the population vote,
so that our elected officials are actually
representative of the general public.
And for the more data driven members of
the audience, I could tell you that if you
are in a swing state, the chance of your
one vote changing the election outcome
is actually 18 times better than
your chance of winning the lottery.
But beyond emotional and
data driven appeals,
I would propose that there are two main
reasons why it's crucial that you vote.
First, oftentimes there
are many things to vote for
on a ballot beyond just people,
especially here in California.
In this November's midterms,
there were 11 different statewide
propositions on California ballots.
Soliciting constituent input on everything
from affordable housing to whether or
not California should abandon
Daylight Savings Time.
And these measures often do pass or
fail on very thin margins.
Second, politicians look at who votes.
Whether or not you vote is a public
record here in the United States.
And that means that, yes,
your neighbors can know whether or
not you voted in the most
recent elections.
But more importantly, it means that
politicians know who voted and
who did not.
And especially at the local level,
when those same politicians are making
decisions about different
policies down the line.
For better for worse, they look at who
voted last time as the projection for
who's likely to vote next time.
That means that if you want to be sure
that your interests are heard in how your
government operates, you have to take on
the mantle of being an active citizen.
Now, for those of you who already vote,
government doesn't only
need you on election day.
There's a whole spectrum of ways to
get involved the rest of the year.
From calling your elected official and
expressing support or concern for an issue
to volunteering for local or national
campaign that you're excited about.
Or getting involved in political tech and
creating a digital solution to help
government better serve the public.
Maybe you help fund
public/private partnerships
to drive toward meaningful social change.
Or maybe you even decide to run for
office, or
otherwise do a tour of duty of
sorts in government yourself.
Today, roles in government are no
longer limited to policy adviser,
project coordinator, and
legislative director.
Today, roles in government include
becoming a presidential innovation fellow,
a user experience designer, or even chief
technology officer of the United States.
These are all real roles that
real people hold in government.
And all of them have been held by someone
who decided to leave Silicon Valley for
a few years and contribute their time and
talents to the change
that they wanted to see.
Toward the end of my
time at the White House,
I found myself standing outside the
Oval Office waiting to begin my farewell
meeting each staffer
gets with the president.
I was trying to remember to breathe
as I nervously counted the stars and
stripes on the lapel pin of
the Secret Service officer across from me.
Before I knew it, a staffer said next,
and ushered me into the Oval Office,
where Barack Obama was standing
in front of the Resolute desk.
Now, I had played this moment over and
over in my mind.
I would thank him and
explain what an honor it was to contribute
in even a small way to his legacy.
And he would thank me and
congratulate me for my work.
But what I remember most
from our conversation that
day is what President Obama
said at the end.
We shook hands to say goodbye and
he paused and
said there's more work to be done.
Not thank you for what you have done and
not congratulations, but
there's more work to be done.
There I was expecting to celebrate
the team's accomplishments to date,
only to have the leader of
the free world remind me
of the never ending list of problems yet
to be solved.
And that is a huge challenge.
But it's also a huge opportunity, and
one in which all of us can play a part.
You may have heard John F Kennedy's quote,
ask not what your country can do for you,
ask what you can do for your country.
But I don't think that's quite right.
Yes, you should ask what you can do for
your country.
But you should also never stop asking
what your country can do for you.
Because if we start thinking about that,
if we start expecting more and
seeing ourselves as
shareholders in government,
then we can truly bring our government
to its fullest potential together.
Because in the end,
there's always more work to be done.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]